car
me
[clapping]
googoo
[music]
[clapping]
tan
[music]
yeah yeah yeah [clapping] [music] [clapping] [music] [clapping] [music] OhOh
yeah yeah
[music]
[clapping]
[music] yeah
yeah ana is nice
[music]
me
[music] yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah  Yeah
anatan
tan tan
tan
[music]
I
ana
tee
[music] yeah yeah yeah
[music]
anh
b
[music]
bl
tan
[music]
cap
ana
b
j
[music]
bl
elf
There
was
[Music]
dj
tan
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] Hmm
[Music]
voodoo
Ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
me
[music]
[music] h [music]
re
[music]
ah ah ah
[music] oh
oh
[clapping]
[music]
me
[clapping]
[music]
goo
erotic
[music]  ]
voodoodanejones
[music]
yeah yeah yeah me yeah yeah yeah wh wh tee me tee t joy yeah yeah yeah
ah ah ah ah
[music]
wh ah ah ah good
voodoo
re
me
ben
uh
[music]
elf
deeme me can book  me
me2
[music]
re
b
goods bl
ana
b
[music]
lanacan
you
[music]
do
j
[music]
ben
bl
tan
tanme eh [music] yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
tj
[  Music]
b 4
pe
[Music]
F
c species pou dou dou
teun yeah
[music]
ana
minutes
ah ah ah me
mmmmm crap info bln me me [music]
with celebee
[music]
bl
dee
voodoo
web
el
war
voodoo
bud yeah
[music
] yeah
[music]
pou
dou
voodoo
yeah
elf
voodoo yeah
voodoo
yeah [music] yeah yeah yeah 4 yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
Tokyo Game Show 2021 Online
Good evening,
microsoft program will be sent from here on
me
[Music]
Hello everyone
Expack Snow view this
to
5 won
this crazy bag ba
Blue Three Eight Tokyo Game  Show
resonator
Arles ping pong ping pong Benz
board game
r 4ds
leader in [ __ ] art s
web app in this free
to do liner
inoreader power wind
app to
do x park a wish awish a
4 ae and [ __ ]
derp
doe
voodootrexta 6 view
Wales presentation
Vision Eve a plane Tinker
Week Team Car Meeting Game
ox Discus japanese
market new
directions for n 3
Wai boys place n one for
support in the
parmanent
panoramas Pro Reamer
Plettsupa to do Loan
for some reason i Musou
please to
do
nu do me Scan Crease 3 Question
Che Power
rde and join to
do for xptasogare a
Mode Hanger Game 2 Steal
Woo Farm otherin terren
d star Repeater Mars
Game Love Porter
Reporting Patty Ranger
Po Navy One Phrase vr Wear
Naruwaa r Wear Wow Red Multiple Owner
Buckses 2 wb you doing Hard
Boys Bar 2 eb
annon bcl 2 p Game
Show
perona tx Parks
Thank you very much.
Hello everyone.
Thank you for participating in the Tokyo Game Show 2021 xbox live stream. My
name is Misuzu Araki and
I look forward to working with you again this year.
Message from Phil Spacer of
No. It was very exciting, so as
I told you, today
we are preparing a special prize that you can enjoy
.
There is a corner
where Japanese game creators can
participate as well as the latest videos, and there are a
lot of various contents. We are also planning to introduce
the game bus and xbox cloud
gaming in detail,
but
first of all, many gay bars are waiting
for the release.  Let's take a look at the latest video of I Saho Raizo 5.
Sir's burgon eu school bag
aimer on love no
voodoo 3
we are the voodoo
nu minute back jelly
franchisor couza cure grace
gel a about just pu rj
f 5 e 2 how do you do you
do scam menu
beads own caper
Peter see  the voodoo
in  Game
[Music]
pou
dou
[Music]
dougenexus Good other
seg Staffway Bus Cover
sperma gsp Dabrander Design
penetrates in 4 minutes Graphics game pou
dou
[Music]
voodoo
voodoomt ex Archer
Star Wars game to do n
Access wages  Path ski gyyu minhanyu
game path to u vinegar bath
with this stock aux pbk
mps crj
you do for a b a r p
g
scull ex min pen dn anchor
s [ __ ] gay bar
bases car web access good
ere
[music] ah [music]
yeah yeah yeah  Masu yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
I
have a promise I made with Nagi
It certainly exists to give me the ash and the aim
I can't understand even if I predict it
[Music]
My follow  Key
this blue
ran I can see all of them
jr Proliferation I ignite the fire and
it's cool to be a good husband
[Applause]
I'm bored with the same look all the time
[Music]
White Come on,
it's been three friendly tours,
so
I'm not free, but I don't know what's going on
. All wards are suddenly old
.
[Music] In
this situation, mother and child
chatting is over.  Taka
[Music]
Is it a secret right? It's
rarely treated as a criminal
[Music]
me
th
tan
Yeah Yeah Yeah, not to mention dead balls
, but please look forward to the announcement of protection from games and nursing game works
here.  Let's hear more about the new possibilities of the game from Dolly by Kareem, who oversees xbox cloud gaming at Microsoft, about
the official launch of xbox cloud gaming in Japan
.  Music]
Hello everyone
4 f is
this
rper Micro Come on nexx
Fairy
my na  me screen charlie
neba packer game dish
mother g 3 regul game g
pve is
jenny fat burning perk seabed game device audio
readerx painting packer
gaming terotero
overwatch ngupagu as
teranex erotic starting
tomorrow n
UPR PCsburn waterland good  ios
windows
Azcarp ni-constant Star
Pearl Gaming Brand 500 won
Open to Tiffir Party Nudie
sbx Pink Orb afferrare
Blinker Gaming Japan
game for as mode multiples
do4 n one hand game
with japanese to
[music]
doin japan World Word Pro
4 and North Wing Beauty  Open pop
mudy advice g o edion [music] fuze romes cab mos play
starting tomorrow
enjoy Douglas and supply game car
Thank you nfc una
eat
I'm selling but
ani
me is there
[music]
mar
9th place Build
It was easy for everyone to
stand me
[Music]
dish
me Oh,
I'm doing it c
I thought I'd do something interesting, do it after I got
home
Yeah
[Music] Yeah
yeah
[  Music]
pandan
when you
do
teruha
[Music]
[Applause]
me
[Music]
Video creator Masodi
This time, we will play immediately because xbox cloud gaming will appear from xbox where you are playing console games.
Awa wants to do it. With
xbox's cloud gaming technology,
more than 100 mixed-run original
pictures windows pc smartphone tablets, etc. It is possible to make trays with Miya-san's bottom vise of Sakurachi.
I
need
an xbox game pass ultimate and a controller. I'd like to play it for a year
now, but I'd like to play the
acquired apartments with xbox cloud gaming of mail farce as soon as possible.
I would like
to introduce you to the special guest lock that you will play with
us on the line site to
this
.
It's about playing dungeons,
but how about Set's
mom mode? It's a minecraft dungeon on this
tablet ipad
. You can play this. This
unique gaming I
want to play on this tablet today.  I think this
guy is episode 9 and I'm on the next
iphone-
I'm doing it with a controller attached here, so
it's
really comfortable By the way, I
'm playing there today Controller
Let's go free with my prop dungeon
Aicha Kiba Something is set for throwing on the back. After all, a
good card is a
little delusional at the beginning.
Well, that chair is good
.
Boober and
Buber's reality, each of them is already
sect. Ah, ah, the economy is
volatile
.
If you connect and register for xbox cloud gaming, you can play games
, and how about being a Revise Fore regardless of location
? If you also
get the xbox Game Pass Ultimate, you can subscribe to later
devices and monthly fees.
You'll be able to enjoy more than 100 games on
Ebisu Box, which makes multiplayer even more
fun Check out the website for more information on cloud gaming.
Thank you for watching until the end today. I'm
gonna wait for you. That renobo
Arles e to
do
voodoo
Do it
.
Taa
ban ban bleacher viper
pro duo rx 6 rings
game are you
do I wonder if I can go back to life I
don't have the scholarship repayment
[Applause]
Boo
Boo Boo Boo
seo
Cafe
[Music]
Great talent in Asia  We
have a large community of indie developers with us,
working with the xbox team
to develop great games every day for xbox bread, and this time we
'd like
to share some of them.  Please
th
r
[Music]
Czech Happy can burn
huh
Her name is
still peace Which is
a photographer living in New York
Why she went to England 4 a This
countryside
Of course there was an interesting subject as a photographer
The reason is that the reason is different from the real reason in front of the building
[Music]
To complete the investigation of the secret that was drunk by the client
and to escape from the debt-covered groove life with a single reversal
[Music]
my birthday
It will be clear soon about the client until the day.
Let's watch her's future together
. Oh
nin
Well, are you ready? A
[Music]
A book presented by my classmates and
that is a new adventure  It was the beginning of the
handmade turbo venture rpg Timelight,
so the art
begins when the class is over. Let's go on an exciting adventure
with the car lights to save the kidnapped princess.
Attacking with,
stealing the mysterious brother of the crafting monster, and
the mechanism unique to hand-drawn animation
color the constitution.
It's time
[Music]
rtc The Legend of
Timelight Soon you will receive Kenta-kun's
notes
me
[Music]
From here, we will
see two legends who are famous in the game industry discussing.
This is a dialogue between phil spencer, who is in charge of xbox, and Shinji Mikami, who is the representative of Word Game Works.
[Music]
Discrete Beaver s play t
Joy Valley Non-landing Curly New
Jim Car mean
voodoo Join the xx family for the first time in a while
I'm very happy to be able to
power swell babo Dave
worker winner ting
game xan 8 view
future
beastilia word game ax, but as usual
young people
give big chances as a studio
to make a new game 2  Mesar
puspa japanese
Pleaser Union Booing d 2 Cold gods game
Deep inn by persone japanese
market leader [ __ ]
japan The Japanese game industry is also
making a big change in various history  It has changed in the middle,
but from my point of view, I am actively engaged in
game design based on Japan's unique sensibilities,
and I feel that it is very attractive to that,
especially the recent
subscription.
I'm very excited to hear that the
cloud makes
it easy to play games without having a console,
and the
game that Pan good wants to make from now on is
ah.
I think that the current situation will be a tailwind.
Specifically, I
've
played a lot of very volumey games, but with
South klipsch, I
can play various games for a fixed amount.
It's
short, but I think
there are a lot of customers who want to play
games because it's very
unique.  There are lots of game finishes for smartphones,
such as Facebook and various
contents, and in Japan, and
there is no time left, so
even for a short time, the game is very unique and
I want to play with a little pinch.  ok
I think that it has become a very attractive market for young people to make new and sharp games with
a lot of customers
anderen gui powder
with.  b Poncho be on
pend 3 Green Lou
Do Well fill in Du Barter
Well, at the moment it has already been announced
Ah
ah 5 A
young creator named Kenji Kimura is
working hard as a director
to leave Tokyo  He has a great talent.
Now, in the words since then, he is a young creator who officially debuted in shoes and
speaks John Jo.
He is now
challenging a new game with Norinori
.  It's not a
game like that for categorization,
but a new
director is taking on the challenge right now
. Very everyone is young,
energetic, talented, and
has a lot of expectations.
I have a question, but I think that the
xbox in the Japanese market
has had quite a big ups and downs in the long history,
but
what do you think about the future Japanese market and how to get
excited?  I
'd like to hear what you're
going to
do.
Pad bbex paint with pc
iphone
irena now swords
web side visor global
japanese game market
nod putty  Is Paper t have
a japanese game for
so low Mutter
far better
benq 5 Creative Working t
you do
Good evening, I'm Best Softworks Japan
Community Manager Dana Bora
's wonderful fallout 7 t 6
Power and works and camp  The best staff from all over the world are also paying attention to how
many screenshots are posted on sns every day and how
Paul & Seventy 6 friends
give advice and support to each
other.
I hope that the
number of players will continue to increase and the
ball art community will continue to grow even more in
the future.
There is a broadcast of Works
. We announced game updates and announcements on Twitter. We
will also announce the winners of the camp contest,
so please take a look
. Thank you for watching the abolition of
microsoft today.  I'm Junko Kawano,
who is in charge of character illustrations for the village and bio
games. Thank you for your cooperation.
We are now
working hard on a new rtg title policy called 100 Heroes
.
Thank you for your continued support.
And this time
, I would like to introduce the second part with 100 au, a story that connects with 100 a hot water. You can play
this game with the xbox game pass
from the release date.
It was
n't the main story when the writer was announced, but there was a
tremendous response in the scene where only a few additions
were made, and we were
a little awesome.
The person who produced Jingu for 100 a years
is in charge of the game studio Natsume, which we trust very much,
and the story
is also that I have been very familiar with Silly for a long
time.  Ru
Satomi will be in charge of slipping.
Yes
, I would like Satomi to explain while watching the play video
. Everyone who is looking forward to the
100 heroic biography.  I'm Satomi, who was in charge of the scenario of Den Rising
.
Let's keep the video under development after 100 Hero Den Mistress.
100 au Ren Rising is 100 Hero
Den.
It is a side-scrolling
action ability ring game with the theme. The
stage is 100 Heroes.
A town called New Labor
in the frontier of the world.  An
ancient ruin was discovered in the basement of the city due to the earthquake
. Starting with that, totalers and merchants who dreamed of making a fortune
gathered from all over the world, and suddenly
the treasure dash came to life
.
100 yen ghost  In the world of the world, the relics of the
magical Miyamoto called the primary lens and the mage range
and the ancient ruins are
of interest to the world view and the story
.
There is a secret behind the fact that there are seats on the second floor of this town,
so it's 100 yen
.
The main characters who appear in the main story of the heroic story are
those who find treasure by transfer, and the
punishment that suffers from the earthquake and suffers from financial difficulties will also contribute to the reconstruction.In
the process, people and adventurers who oppose the excavation of the ruins
The key to the conspiracy to
shake the world in the back of such a treasure hunting adventure
is that the house is in
the foreground, so
100 yen hot water  Since it is the main
story, I hope you enjoy the 100 Heroes Rising, which is studded with information
.
Thank you very much for playing and I am very much looking forward
to
future policies around Natsume. Thank
you
and everyone at 100 au.
Please look forward to future information on both 100 a day rising
.
Nice to meet you,
sweat is again ah
[music]
[clapping]
bejean
yeah dee yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
[music]
[clapping] yeah
yeah  Yeah
Cars 2
kj
Ranger is nice
can
[Music]
me
Besides
rr
Ale Story
voodoo
voodoonp xbox one Imamura
r treason Joy dje
Thank you
adele
Sukki seems to be having fun
and misunderstanding us  No,
I need to sacrifice when I know it
[Music]
I'm quill paying for
diplomatic unity, isn't it?
I'm really grateful for
what happened when I was attacked by the moment I came
in. That's a
good two-day question.
For example
, I wonder if I want
to know the truth.
Music]
Boo Boo
Book
[Music]
Koi
me
[Music]
[Applause]
I sent you a
microsoft program.
After this, Konami's program will start at 19:00
Tokyo Game Show 2021 online
Please continue to enjoy